let's let's start with a really really
important question something I've always
wanted to know when I watch movies that
are filmed in the pristine snowy
landscapes how do you go about getting
all of your cast and crew and equipment
there and not disturbing the snow for
the shots how come it looks so pristine
when you've been all over the place
clearly and you don't have a CGI budget
I would imagine well a lot of it is VFX
cleaner but you have to be very careful
about how you plan the day and how you
move equipment in move the the crew in I
mean for this film the mode of
transportation with snowmobiles and cats
a lot of the time so that was a huge
learning curve for a lot of the people
who hadn't shot and snow before so but
visual effects in the end of the day can
help make things look pristine Matthew
can you talk about how all you decided
on all three of these actors my
understanding is Elizabeth came on on
the earlier side
Jeremy you came out on the later ride so
how did it all come so when I get the
script Lizzie was already on board and
was the first and last choice and I
thought it was a great choice Gil as he
said had known Taylor from hella high
water
it's comentary er back then I read the
script before either film was in
production so I didn't know who Taylor
Sheridan was or I just went off the
script and we read this amazing script
but he I think it was the winter of 2000
I got to get my dates around here 15 16
he wanted to go that winter and punting
was not an option so we had as we were
coming to November we were talking about
the Corey role and he called me up one
day and said well what about Jeremy
Renner and I was he'd be amazing
let's let's do this and I think I think
I think Taylor wrote you a note at some
point yeah yeah any he read the note
over
find to me that he was sending Jeremy I
realize he was a very good rider at that
point because I was a great self but I
think we flew Tyler in and he met at
your house and so did the note turn the
tide as far as to get you to open it as
quickly as you did what would have
happened if he hadn't written that extra
note I would be sitting here really yeah
hey there's a lot of people in my life
it did I trust in love I work for a very
long time that we should read this yeah
you got to read this like now I'm not
reading anything I'm I've been the daddy
[ __ ] off essentially it's on everybody
and then finally Taylor came around like
ever get everyone I loved and trusted
like you gotta read this it's amazing I
don't care how amazing it is
um I'm a dad I'm retiring about here and
then at Taylor Taylor he left a
voicemail and he said his note and
ultimately what grab me it's like dude
just read this is all I remember from
the note weathers eloquent or not is
like dude just read [ __ ] ten pages of
this thing if it sucks I'm going to buy
you amazing bottle of booze and we're
shared together and have a great time
like okay okay okay okay I'll read this
thing so I read the first ten pages and
I might just ask
there's ass it's amazing and you know I
could I could not say no then I had to
think ah gate was not directed a movie
before however they need to go down that
road with the first time director this
guy walks into my house and asked a few
questions to him and his emotional
intelligence
he looks look to connect like a cowboy
but he's eloquent and Shakespearean and
thoughtful and emotional compassionate
and as they come and I could not say no
I'm like let's go do this and I'm then
what's it like for the two of you
obviously you've worked together before
on the Avengers movie is kind of a
different budget and I'm sure some
different creature comforts then you
would have film different costumes in
fact is it fun to then after the two of
you know each other a bit to work on
something that's as kind of intimate and
scrappy as this film having done
huge budget is film together yeah I mean
absolutely cuz I think my the first time
I met Jeremy was a really overwhelming
experience shooting the end of Avengers
age of Ultron in Italy and we were like
assuring two hundred extras into a
spaceship that wasn't there and and I
was like I've never got this before
what's going on and Jeremy like hat like
hadn't like held my hands there
everybody was helping me out and to go
from there to literally holding on to
him on a snowmobile going down a
mountain I don't know how fast we would
be going without like any seatbelt
obviously you're just like holding on
with your thighs and your hands and it
does help to have that kind of trust in
some wanted to have a kind of history
but also when we were filming Avengers
our characters oddly enough have very
like close relationship where he kind of
becomes a family member or they kind of
rely on one another so it was it was
something that we I think we were both
happy to get to actually flesh out
characters together and I know for me I
felt like I had an amazing opportunity
to get to work with Jeremy and get to
learn from him and a different in a
different landscape and world of a film
because you the Avenger films are a lot
of funds I think we all know that it's
it's um it's it's you don't get as much
time to dive deep and with something
like this you get to learn from really
great actors and directors and you get
to have that time Gil do you have like a
Taylor Sheridan shrine in your house I
mean I would just imagine between this
movie and hell or high water you've been
at this for so long and doing working so
steadily but I think you have two of the
best roles of your career written by
this guy and it's really allowed you to
shine in such a cool way order I'm dead
it to him forever and he's an all right
guy
now I love Taylor I've loved him from
the for the first time that we met but
and it's not over our journeys not over
but yeah I mean it's you just feel so so
blessed to be able to come across a
rider like that it's so rare and then to
have the opportunity to kind of portray
characters that you feel you know secure
and and viscerally know they know what
they're talking about you know
especially from a native point of view
and he could have only gotten that
because of the time he spent with so
many people you know and then just the
respect and the love that he has for
those characters
yeah I've been I'm eternally indebted to
that man Matthew how did you feel
confident I mean Taylor I guess has
directed a horror movie like six years
ago but I mean this essentially is
directorial debut for him how did you
feel comfortable as one of the financial
people behind this film that he could
handle this as well as he did I mean I
after I read it I we organized a call
and I spoke to Taylor for about two
hours and at the end of that two hours I
thought well if he can't do this nobody
can he's he knows what he wants how he
wants to get it he knew who he wanted to
work with from the crew to the I mean he
was just very very prepared and there
was no changing his mind even if you did
disagree within which I didn't so I
thought no one should try you know
exactly if you have and if you have less
with a tail between their legs but the
I'm right Lisa
well I congratulate all four of you on
this it's such a powerful film so
beautifully done